hey youtubers is charlie welcome to my
very first South Park stick of truth
video anytime I do gameplay videos I'll
try and include as much commentary on
the show as is relevant to the action
there are a lot of things about the game
that I've already noticed that really
make it the best licensed game I've ever
seen and even after you finish the game
there's still the fun of going back and
looking for all the little touches they
added in the development process just to
make it feel like an interactive episode
rather than just being a sweet RPG in
case anyone's wondering I haven't quite
set my camera up for game capture of my
face that is so I'm actually probably
going to buy like a small camera just
amount on my computer just to make a
little bit easier since my big camera
that I use my other videos just a little
too cumbersome before we get started
though I need to crown some winners in
my steam giveaway congratulations to
Swinney the one and furry fear you guys
went to 20 delta gift cards want a piece
that is I'll be messaging you both on
your channels for details so quick show
of hands down in the comments let me
know if you've won bought the game and
to which class you've rolled your first
time through that is if you blew through
on release day and you're replaying on
other classes you definitely deserve a
high five the best games are always
worth playing more than once back when I
was in college I was a swimmer so during
the summers I still had to train with my
team two or three times a day you know
Michael Phelps style in order to keep
from going crazy in between all those
practices I would just sit on my ass and
play all of the classic final fantasy
games on my old playstation I had to go
to an old vintage store to find them
just because they were really old even
then but when I wasn't passed out i
would spend you know maybe like 80 90
hours playing those games it was so much
fun that's also how I read Harry Potter
for a couple of summers it was the best
vacation ever final fantasy is still my
favorite RPG series but whenever a world
of warcraft was released a long time ago
I really drank the kool-aid hard and
spend most of my time on it up till
wrath of lich king then i did that thing
where ever you play an MMO way too much
and then you take a break for a year or
two and then come back I'm not playing
it right now just because I'm spending
all my time making YouTube videos which
is actually probably the best social
game ever created and yes that's right I
totally just called YouTube of social
game so let's dive into stick of truth
for anyone that's wondering my rig at
home is a custom core i5 with a 760 GT
in a Korean 1440 monitor I'm thinking
about going back to to 24 inch monitors
but we'll see sometimes having that
giant monitor makes it a little hard to
multitask for this intro vid I'll just
say a little bit about the aspects of
the game that I find really interesting
so far and if anyone has an opinion on
it I did turn subtitles on in the game
just for let's play videos for anyone
that really likes subtitles so if you
guys hate them just let me know and I'll
turn them off so one of the first things
that you notice about the game is how
the characters move through the
environment it works a lot like a 2d
adventure game even though you're moving
in three-dimensional space it's one of
the tropes of the series that it's
purposefully made to look really shitty
which is kind of funny one of the best
parts being that you kind of figure out
you know how you can fart all the time
right away raise your hand if you make
your character fart non-stop for about
three or four minutes that you figured
that out thinking about farts is Magic
actually underscores one of the biggest
criticisms of the game so far at least
from major critics and that a lot of the
jokes are repeated which personally I
don't mind that much just because they
are pretty funny and a lot of times if
you're too focused on certain aspects of
the game you'll miss that so whenever
you replay on a different class you'll
always catch little things that you
missed even though Matt Stone and Trey
Parker were really involved in this long
process obsidian was the one that did
most of the legwork and developing the
game they're still kind of on my [ __ ]
list for messing with Knights of the Old
Republic too but that was so long ago
that I kind of had to bury the hatchet
because this is actually going to be a
really fun game they really did a good
job so early on in the game it's fairly
benign it's mostly you know tutorial
mode so some of the crazier aspects of
the game don't really happen until much
much later in the narrative but if any
of you actually have played the censored
version of the game it's really just an
abortion and a couple other you know
really graphic things that were taken
out and even though the South Park
creators already spoke about it they did
say that it kind of sucked that that had
to happen the decision to do that was
mostly a marketing decision just so that
makes the game more profitable so they
can market it in broader ways a good
example of this is an r-rated movie when
a movie is rated R they can only market
it in certain ways during certain times
of the day so a much smaller portion of
people will see ads and go see the movie
and it
potentially make less money so when
they're making a video game you know
obviously they want everyone in the
world to buy a copy so they have to kind
of tweak it a little bit especially in
foreign countries where censorship laws
are a little bit different than they are
in the US the game is relatively bug
free so far but there are a couple bugs
that people have reported there are a
couple of boss fights that bug out a
little bit and on the ps3 version some
people have been reporting like a poor
framerate issue but for the large part
the games actually relatively bug free
which is amazing most games are super
buggy whenever they release one of my
favorite things about the game so far is
the way it prompts you especially in the
tutorial mode and the fact that Eric
Cartman calls you a douche bag no matter
what you name yourself a good example is
when you stand still for too long and
erik Hartman says something like don't
worry it's not like there's a game to be
played it creates this real sense of
urgency that lends itself to something
you would see in an episode building
towards a big battle or climax the
douchebag stuff in the way that Eric
Cartman and other characters interact
with you as you talk to them is
definitely because of the creator's
involvement it goes a long way to making
it feel like a real interactive episode
and that's just because Matt Stone and
Trey Parker were so involved in the
process so my next stick of truth video
is just gonna be another regular
gameplay video I'll try to get my camera
fixed by then just so i can add my face
to the videos just because it's a little
bit more fun but there's a bunch of
other big stuff happening this weekend
i'm trying to get through Doctor Who
more Game of Thrones Walking Dead on
Sunday everyone's asking about community
I'm trying to catch up on all that stuff
real life work this week was just really
shitty so I had to take a lot of time
away from making videos but hopefully
I'll be full-time creator sometime soon
and I'll only be making videos that's
really the dream that's the dream be
sure to let me know if there's anything
specific that you want from gameplay
videos I'll try and point out Easter
eggs and like little fun things about
episodes and stuff but for this intro
video I didn't want to get too deep into
it so since it's the weekend and I'd
love to do anime stuff on the weekend
click here to watch my top 10 anime
characters and click here to learn about
my top 5 anime reboots thanks so much
for watching I will see you guys again
later tonight I'm gonna try and post
another video
they'll fly up hopefully by eight or
nine o'clock at night thanks guys high
fives
you